es ist eine neue bewegung im gange im
netz und zwar gegen die drossel kommt
die telekom die in zukunft die
datenraten ihrer dsl leitung beschränken
will wenn man zu viel datenvolumen
abruft und dagegen gibt es eine petition
ins leben gerufen wurde sie vom alte
götz und auch eine demo am 16.5 den köln
und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit ihm
die lage die lage ist immer super
okay das heißt wie viele unterzeichner
einer petition gibt es jetzt
wir sind mittlerweile weit über 100
75.000 die genaue zahl noch gar nicht im
kopf dass aktualisiert sich einfach
stünden richter kommen ordentlich leute
hinzu und ja wie ist das ganze passiert
wie bist du dazu gekommen diese petition
aufzusetzen und zum zweiten die so ist
diese erfolgreich also erstmal nichts
weil wird bekommen eine news mittel
telekom mit den neuen tarifen hat mir
gedacht das kann eigentlich nicht wahr
sein also die telekom möchte einen neuen
tarifen liegt neben erster qualität
quasi beerdigen indem sie halt die
datenpakete von sich selber und von
anderen anbietern die mit ihr
kooperierenden anders behandelt als
pakete grundsätzlich und dadurch
entsteht eben eine klassengesellschaft
und es heißt wenn ich jetzt youtube
nutzer dann wird es vielleicht
gedrosselt weil youtube nicht mit
telekom call probierte ich jetzt aber
bei der konkurrenzen video schauen wie
zum beispiel vimeo awards einfach
flüssig durch weil die eben die telekom
extra dafür bezahlen
und das ist natürlich etwas was
eigentlich keinen gefallen sollte weil
dadurch verliert das netz an vielfalt
und ja das möchte eigentlich niemand zum
punkt warum die warum das ganze so
erfolgreich geworden ist ich war selbst
erstaunt als der protest im netz war ja
schon ziemlich groß aber eigentlich ja
muss man erst mal so eine große masse
darauf aufmerksam machen dass so eine
petition genau das ist schwierig ich
hatte die position erst mal halt auch
facebook und twitter verbreitet hat das
erstmal ein bisschen selber sein
auch genommen weil ich eben das
riesenglück dass ich beim rbb nach nach
1000 unterschriften schon zum radio
interview eingeladen wurde und dadurch
hat das ganze ziemlich ja ziemlich
gesteigert
du hast jetzt gab gesprochen von einer
klassengesellschaft ich sag mal wie
oasis youtube aber auch der nutzer ist
ungleich gestellt weil der eine der kann
sich leisten einen besseren tarif zu
bekommen und der andere nicht richtig
genau das natürlich auch ein absolutes
problem weil wenn nicht gedrosselt bin
dann kann ich kaum noch mit die
tagesschau zum beispiel online anschauen
derjenige der märz hat kann auch schon
und so gesehen wird auch einfach die die
informationsquelle mir quasi genommen
was natürlich ein riesiges problem
darstellt ok und jetzt geht quasi ein
wahrer proteststurm los die petition war
erst der anfang
es wird eine demo geben was wird da
passieren richtig genau also es wird zur
aktionärsversammlung am 16
bei einer demo geben die beginnt um 18
30 erstmal mit einer mahnwache das heißt
wir wollen die aktionäre die daten
kommen das fünf- bis zehntausend wollen
wir erstmal darüber informieren was die
telekom davor hat und warum das falsch
ist und dann wird es eine richtige demo
geben ab 16 uhr bis 18 uhr
und ja da wird neuer wird es dann eine
reden geben und wir werden halt noch mal
dass die öffentlichkeit einfach so
dorthin weisen wir hoffen natürlich dass
auch alle pressevertreter da sind das
gesamte öffentliche wo findet das ganze
stadt an der lanxess arena dort findet
die aktionärsversammlung stadt also
lanxess arena köln in köln 38 das ist in
der nähe des deutzer bahnhofs eigentlich
sehr gut für erreichen
absolut also da kommt man super mit
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
und was erhoffst du dir von der ganzen
aktion
was erhoffen wir von der aktion ja ich
habe einfach davon dass die telekom das
ganze doch noch mal ein bisschen über
denk ich konnte er schon die ersten 130
tausend unterschriften mit telekom
übergeben bzw telekom deutschlandchef
niek jan van damme und hatten auch ein
45 minütiges gespräch mit ihm
wo ich noch mal erklären konnte was
meine kritik daran ist und wir haben
natürlich die ausstellung dass die
telekom doch noch einlenkt und das ganze
zurücknimmt
was denkst du wie kommt es dazu weil die
angebote der flatrates die gab es zuerst
von den telekommunikationsunternehmen
jetzt wird es wieder zurückgenommen
großes thema ist eben die
netzneutralität das heißt der
ungefilterte und gleichberechtigte
zugang zu allen diensten und allen
anbietern
es geht ja auch darum dass zb du oder
ich wenn wir eine eigene webseite haben
im videoplayer der werden wir ja nie mit
der telekom einen vertrag darüber
schließen können ein bevorzugter
serviceseiten zu können ja was ist der
hintergrund des ganzen und wohl öfter
setzen also die telekom behauptet auch
für so kleine leute wie uns wäre das
möglich ich bezweifle dass natürlich
auch stark
das muss natürlich abwarten
hat die politik geschlafen ist meine
frage oder wo liegt der fehler im system
oder hat sie haben die kommunikations
konzerne zu früh die flatrates angeboten
oder muss es so was wie flatrates geben
in einer gesellschaft die sich primär
über das internet informiert was ist da
sein standpunkt also die politik hat
auch so ein bisschen verschlafen und
deshalb qualität müsste eigentlich
wirklich festgeschrieben werden
gesetzlich nur weil nur so können wir
eigentlich
informationsfluss gewährleisten und ja
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das immer
besser formulieren würde also ich denke
ich denke die politik musste auf jeden
fall handeln weil ansonsten an jetzt
ähnliches problem wie flatrates
mythischen sachs kunden den
telekommunikationsunternehmen eingeführt
die telekom argumentiert jetzt
sie müsste das zurücknehmen weil sie
eben netz ausbauen muss und dafür
einfach richtig viel geld brauchen klar
netzausbaus teuer aber es halt die frage
ob die finalisierung so sinnvoll ist
wie sieht es jetzt plant weil angeblich
sind drei prozent der nutzer betroffen
laut telekom das würde bedeuten dass die
einnahmen doch ziemlich gering werden
die sie zusätzlich machen würden
und deswegen macht dieser grund quasi
eigentlich wiederum ausgehebelt dass man
dass man dadurch den netzausbau
finanzieren möchte weil die einnahmen so
viel es mäßig gering sind das denn für
ein konzern wie die telekom eigentlich
nichts ausmacht gut also sieht sich
einmal an natürlich wie ein bisschen
verworrene lage man kommt ja auch an
solche informationen nur mittelbar heran
bedarf es eines weckruf an die politik
auf jeden fall
wir werden auch die petition noch mal
bisschen mehr an die politik richten in
den nächsten tagen und wollen halt auch
die politik so ein bisschen dafür
interessieren jetzt gerade im wahlkampf
ist natürlich auch ja eigentlich ein
besucher möglichkeit weil die politik da
sich natürlich gerne irgendwie so ein
paar wahlkampfziel gesucht und wenn wir
das da das als wahlkampf des wahlkampfs
ja ziel so mehr oder weniger etablieren
könnten lässt natürlich prima eine
chance für ein revival der piratenpartei
also die piratenpartei engagiert sich da
natürlich auch mit aber nicht nur
durchgerannt anteil es gibt etliche
andere scheinen sich dafür einsetzen
also die geht es nicht um parteipolitik
sondern die geht es um design um das
klassische es gibt absolut
um parteien sondern ja um das nicht
parteipolitisch okay dann sind wir alle
gespannt was am 16.5 dort passiert wie
viel kommen wir haben es ja schon bei
acta gesehen dass übers netz wirklich
zehntausende mobilisiert werden können
das wird ein bisschen enger lanxess
arena während sehen und schauen wir mal
wie es mit dem drossel funk weiter geht
vielen dank genau und wer eben das
vielleicht nicht zur demo schafft
nachdem würdest du einfach dazu bitten
ein kurzes video aufzunehmen und auf
youtube hochzuladen
wo er einfach mal seiner oma das thema
netzneutralität erklärt weil das ist
nämlich extrem kompliziertes thema
netzneutralität einfach zu erklären
und deswegen war einfach so ein bisschen
die idee ja man muss das eigentlich
vereinfachen und ja wäre einfach
supercool wenn das paar leute machen
würden einfach den hashtag irgendwie
weiß nicht netzneutralität erklärt für
oma irgendwie mit in den titel rein und
dann dann findet man das auch also fan
ist supercool
dort kommen sollte wahrscheinlich auto
entsteht das war ich auch noch genau
vielen dank malte und ja schauen wir mal
bis dann tschüss bis dann job